ce qui est dommageable dans cette
affaire c'est que nous le personnel
soignant on avait commencé à faire face
à cette affaire on était passé à autre
chose
le fait qu'on ressorte les vieux
dossiers qui est d'ailleurs tout un
tapage médiatique autour de cette
affaire c'est plutôt ça que le personnel
risque de mal vivre parce qu'on va faire
se remettre dans cette affaire est
clairement nous personnes et soignons
n'avait pas du tout envie qu'on est
vraiment passé à autre chose et la
défense de pêcher dit il peut y avoir
encore un espoir un empoisonneur en
liberté quelque part ils essayent de se
défendre comme ils peuvent à c'est sûr
maintenant pourquoi pas après qui enfin
bon ça n'en finit plus nous clairement
la sphère judiciaire nous nous concerne
pas le travail de la police nous
concerne pas nous ce qui nous intéresse
c'est de pouvoir continuer à faire notre
notre métier de la manière la plus calme
possible la plus professionnelle aussi
en toute tranquillité
on reparle tout de même dans des
périodes et les périodes où le docteur
pesci exerçait de fortes tensions quand
même dans les équipes médicales du jour
des tensions dans les équipes médicales
de plus particulièrement au bloc 1 après
vous êtes sur un type de personnalité
c'est des gens sur les chirurgiens
anesthésistes
c'est toujours très compliqué de
travailler avec eux une ambiance de
blocs sont de toute manière par
définition très tendue et c'était pas
plus tendue pareil j'étais pas plus
tendue qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète vous
aujourd'hui alors c'est vraiment le
déficit d'image à la clinique est ce qui
pourrait en résulter
nous bien entendu ce qui nous inquiète
en tant que prétend toute personnelle
c'est l'impact économique que cette
affaire pour avoir sur sur
l'établissement
une fin aussi très bien que si notre
notoriété atteinte s'arrêter aussi une
baisse de fréquentation qui dit baisse
de fréquentation dit baisse de chiffres
qui dit baisse de chiffres din ont
atteint 2 budgétaire derrière on sait
très bien que c'est personnel qui va en
faire les frais c'est une évidence
nos craintes elles sont là donc l impact
économique a un impact aussi
psychologique
à savoir aussi que quand même une
certaine pression qu'exerçait sur le
personnel on sait très bien qu'on n'a
plus le droit à l'erreur et qu'au
moindre faux pas la moindre erreur on se
doit de tout justifier
il ya des pros c'est ce qu'ont été mis
en place aujourd'hui clairement il ya
des procès squatter mise en place on a
un établissement qui est hyper sécurisé
avec de plus en plus maintenant de deux
verrous électroniques pour le moindre
petit incident ont fait ces fameuses
déclarations d'incident grave pour le
moins petit problème le personnel de
justifier d'aller créer sur les dossiers
c'est une évidence
on a bien senti dans les suites de la
faire il ya deux ans quand même une
certaine pression moi je l' ai ressenti
comme ça de certaines pressions
supplémentaires qui s'exerçait sur le
personnel ou maintenant se doit
d'attirer plus irréprochable